naja wie rasen etwas ganz anderes aber
auch sehr aktuell corona wir rasen im
blindflug in den nächsten krone lockdown
und machen die gleichen fehler die in
den letzten jahren in deutschland weit
steigen die zahlen außer
interessanterweise im osten deutschlands
aber die instanzen im westen auch im
saarland steigen und steigen einig sind
sich wieder mal fast alle über die
konsequenzen für den kommenden herbst
währenddessen
gilt es nach den befürwortern der korona
master masken pflicht in innenräumen auf
jeden fall auch einen lock down in
schulen will gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach nicht ausschließen
währenddessen kommunizieren die
gesundheitsämter immer noch per fax und
was ist eigentlich geworden aus dem
ganzen lüftungsanlagen in unseren
schulen aus den digitalisierungs
maßnahmen und aus dem recht auf home
office für alle das sollte doch mal eine
dauerhafte institution werden alles
schall und rauch schon fordern die
ersten wieder ein bundesweites im
register oder den vierten peaks den
bundeskanzler inklusive also die vierte
impfung wobei völlig unklar ist ob die
hilft gegen die neuen varianten
den berühmten b a4 und a5 oder ganz neu
pa 75 neue varianten des corona virus
ich meine missbrauch kein anhaltenden
kontrollwahn es braucht auch keine neue
masken pflicht es braucht auch keinen
neuen locker und für schuhen was es
braucht ist mehr eigenverantwortung wir
sehen doch schon jetzt dass in
öffentlichen räumen viele menschen
wieder mit masken unterwegs sind weil
sie sich selber schützen wollen weil sie
auch diese eigenverantwortung tragen was
ihm zwei jahren pandemie nicht besser
wurde das wird auch im dritten jahr
nicht besser und deswegen im gegenteil
die menschen haben gelernt sich selbst
zu vertrauen und sich selber zu schützen
deswegen bin ich dafür gibt den menschen
das kommando denn wenigstens sie wissen
was sie tun frau wagenknecht ist denn
mit einem gesundheitsminister carlotta
macht das überhaupt möglich dass die
bürger das kommando zurück erhalten na
da kann man ernsthafte zweifel daran
haben wollen natürlich kann ja bitte
gesundheitsminister alleine ja auch
nicht alles machen also letztlich muss
das die bundesregierung beschließen und
wenn die fdp ausnahmsweise zu dem steht
was sie so ankündigen dann müsste das
eigentlich klar sein dass es im herbst
nicht nochmal solchen unsinn gibt wie 2g
und 3g oder gar schulschließungen und
ähnliches ich meine jetzt auch der der
sachverständigenausschuss dem hat man ja
ausdrücklich die aufgabe gegeben er soll
evaluieren wie die maßnahmen gewirkt
hatte lauterbach gesagt das gutachten
darf jetzt auch kein bremsklotz sein hat
er ja ich finde ich finde das eine
frechheit ich meine da sind da ist eine
gruppe von wissenschaftlern und die
arbeiten meines wissen seit märz 21 also
wirklich eine sehr lange zeit und das
sind ja renommierte kluge leute so und
dann gibt es nach fast anderthalb jahren
so ein bericht der ausdrücklich
erwünscht wurde und der bericht war
jetzt sicherlich nicht so wie lauterbach
sich das vorgestellt hat weil es war ja
klar also die meisten maßnahmen sind
durchgefallen und außerdem wurde noch
mal sehr deutlich kritisiert dass wir in
deutschland eine daten wüsste haben also
dass wir eigentlich gar nichts wissen
wir wissen nicht wie viele leute sind
wirklich infiziert wir wissen nicht wie
viele sind wegen corona im krankenhaus
wir wissen bis heute nicht wie viele
menschen sterben an corona also es ist
eigentlich eine katastrophe so und das
haben ja die diese wissenschaftler sehr
klar gesagt und haben gesagt ja gut wenn
man jetzt was sinnvolles machen wird
dann muss man die datenlage verbessern
aber ansonsten ist völlig klar also 2g
3g hat schon deshalb keinen sinn weil
die impfung ja keinen schutz gibt gegen
infektionen das heißt was für mich
daraus folgt ist auch das schleunigst
diese einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht
abgeschafft werden muss
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
also die haben mir immer noch nah so
dass leute die in
gesundheitseinrichtungen arbeiten die
haben das damoklesschwert und teilweise
wird das ja auch praktiziert das sie
gekündigt werden weil sie nicht geimpft
sind obwohl die garantiert auch selber
chocolat vielleicht ein oder zwei weil
durch krankenhaus
es ist völlig unsinnig so und deswegen
finde ich also man darf hier lauterbach
nicht machen lassen ich erwarte dass man
dieses gutachten ernst nimmt und ich
hoffe sehr dass das wofür sie auch
plädieren wirklich im herbst eintritt
also wer eine maske tragen möchte der
kann jedoch tragen ist doch überhaupt
kein problem ob man sind sie für die
einrichtungs beziehungen im schlecht
also ich bin da so ein bisschen hin- und
hergerissen weil ich bin geimpft ich
sehe mich auch
alles richtig und alles gut ich werde
mir auch die vierte impfung geben lassen
es so weit ist denn ich bin 65 und ab 60
sollte man schon ein bisschen auf sich
aufpassen dass ich natürlich trotzdem
überträger sein kann ist ganz klar also
aber ich bin da egoistisch ich will
einfach nicht dass es mich trifft denn
ich habe einige im bekanntenkreis die an
langkow mitleidenden junge leute und
wenn man das mal sieht was da passiert
wenn die zwei treppen hoch gehen und
vorher waren sie tolle sportler und die
kommen noch kaum die treppe hoch da
denke ich mir eben selbst sagt jeder
kann übertragen ja
eigentlich schutz argument ja eigentlich
mac oder hatte also doch also im
endeffekt also ich stütze mich ganz so
einfach gefühle mir einfach selber
entscheiden das ist einfach eine
egoistische haltung von mir ich finde ja
ich werde kämpfen lassen möchte gerade
ältere menschen
dem sollte man die vierte impfung
anbieten die datenlage ist da meines
erachtens relativ unklar ob sie hilft
oder nicht aber wer das für sich möchte
der sollte das auch können also
überhaupt alle fragen nicht mehr weil
niemand so viel druck gesetzt was sie
nicht mehr passieren darf ist ein lock
down also das hat das haben wir jetzt
gesehen das ist ja wirklich auch für
unsere wirtschaft das war ja das war ja
furchtbar ist auch wir wir künstler und
selbstständige wir haben ja da wirklich
wahnsinnig drunter gerieten alle alle
tragen dass er noch ein bisschen hinter
sich her also da bin ich auch voll der
meinung also locker und geht überhaupt
nicht um den schulen auch nicht weil die
die jetzt das abitur gemacht haben mich
meine ich werde euch gefallen muss
ehrlich sagen wenn ich ein jahr lang nur
online irgendwie was ich hätte das
abitur habe ich geschafft und von dem er
gesehen denke ich mir sind die wirklich
zählt das ungerechteste abitur ja auch
das scheint ja das kommt ja zu masken
pflicht beim sport nicht meine das gab
es ja alles die kinder ganztagsschulen
von morgens acht bis nachmittags um vier
mit masken in der schule und unter
gleichen also obwohl ist es gab auch
davor und so weiß nicht wann bei über
zwei jahre lang und wenn es wieder
anfangen soll wieder lockt downs oder
wieder der gleichen oder oder in schulen
dann
fernunterricht sein soll dann muss man
sagen dann haben wir was wirklich falsch
gemacht aber nochmals zurück ich frage
mich wirklich was mit diesen ganzen
maßnahmen ist ja angekündigt worden von
den luftfiltern bis hin zur
digitalisierung gibt es das jetzt gibt
es das nicht die datenaustausch über den
gesundheitsämtern das war ja teilweise
so und diese offenbar immer noch so dass
die daten per fax übermittelt wurden und
dann von einer excel-tabelle die man im
eigenen computer hatten aber nicht
übertragen werden durften dann hände hat
überschauen wurden abgeschrieben gefaxt
dann war das fax papier nicht da da
mussten sie mit der post transportiert
werden also vorsintflutlich ungefähr zu
ein bisschen die bestandsaufnahme wo
stehen wir da jetzt und sind wir jetzt
zum weiter wie er immer wieder
versprochen wurde oder eben auch nicht
also ich finde auch ein thema ist nach
wie vor und ich finde es skandalös dass
da lauterbach eben auch überhaupt nichts
gemacht hat das ist der pflegenotstand
also die situation in krankenhäusern ist
ja wirklich schlimm also für die
pflegekräfte weil es einfach zu wenige
gibt also umso schlimmer ist es dass nur
noch einigen den stuhl vor die tür setzt
weil sie nicht geimpft sind und andere
gehen weil sie weil sie ausgebrannt sind
und in nrw wird gestreikt seit wochen
für bessere arbeitsbedingungen und es
passiert nichts und das finde ich auch
ganz schlimm weil natürlich wenn man
sieht dass krankenhäuser und immer
weniger personal ist dass die
katastrophale arbeitsbedingungen haben
dass sich natürlich auch viel zu wenig
verdienen für die schwere arbeit die sie
machen dann ist doch völlig klar dass es
im herbst wieder notsituation geben wird
ich habe vor kurzem ihr im bericht
angeguckt hat man gedacht dass wir aus
der korona zeit da war eine hd bericht
operationen verschoben
notstand alle notaufnahmen dicht und
dann habe ich geguckt von wann war der
von 2018 in der pit grippewelle also das
ist schon damals so gewesen und wir
schauen dazu und dann wird immer so
getan ja jetzt müssen wir aber doch auf
jeden fall freiheitseinschränkung machen
weil sonst können die die situation in
krankenhäusern ja nicht wieder im griff
können wir nicht in den griff kriegen
nein wir müssen die bessere pflege
bessere arbeitsbedingungen schaffen
bessere löhne dann gibt es auch genügend
ausgebildete pfleger in deutschland
übrigens die arbeit nur in anderen jobs
und euren teilweise ja gibt es
untersuchungen also es gibt eine
befragung die hat verdi mal gemacht die
hatte und das war noch direkt vor
gewohnheit das waren 3 1000 leute also
nicht alle befragt aber die ihren job in
den letzten jahren verlassen haben
ausgebildete pflege auch die haben die
repräsentativbefragung unter solchen
leuten gemacht und da kam raus die
hälfte würde in ihrer arbeit
zurückkehren als pfleger wenn die
arbeitsbedingungen anders wäre
eigentlich ständig gefordert wäre
wahnsinnig da können wir uns glaube ich
das ist das schöne ich glaube wir können
die sendung so ändern dass wir alle uns
bessere bedingungen für die pflege wird